we're going to do something quite
different in terms of
puzzle and and violets a recursive
recursive puzzle or it's going to play
out to be a recursive solution it looks
quite different from from the from the N
Queens puzzle right and so this is gonna
be a tiling puzzle and so I set up the
puzzle and then we're going to take a
little segue off into into a canonical
recursive algorithm called merge sort
all right because I think it it's good
for you to see that algorithm before you
dive into solving this particular puzzle
because it kind of shows you the way all
right and but but I'll set up the puzzle
I guess I didn't have to erase this
square it's it's a courtyard that I has
a bunch it's tile you're supposed to
tile it and it's all square tiles and
I'll just make it 8 by 8 like like a
chessboard and in general we're going to
say that this is a 2 raise to n by 2
raise to n courtyard all right and I
want to I want to tile this courtyard
so this is a treat ah if some people
call it a trauma no you can think of it
it's really an l-shaped aisle and it can
be oriented in any different way I mean
it could be an inverted L etc and I
you're supposed to tile this courtyard
using l-shaped tiles or trauma nose and
they call trauma nose because there's
three tiles and they're three squares in
there and so so that's your that's your
job right I guess kind of a weird job
but you know this is a puzzle and so
you're out there with 2 raise to n by 2
raise to n and all you have are these
l-shaped aisles and you're not allowed
to break them I mean if you break them
then that's not considered a valid
tiling that's bad and that's that's your
job right so I is this Oh and and and
obviously this is it needs to look like
this it needs to look like the floor
maybe you're allowed to to see the the
markings because these are tiles after
all but you can't have something that is
uneven you can have the tile on top of
another tile I mean that's a definite
no-no and you can't not have a tile in
any part of the courtyard right so
that's I think that was kind of obvious
but it's worth explicitly stating just
so we don't we don't get confused here
right so I so that's that that's the
question that we're going to try and
answer but as I said I want to talk
about something a little bit different
for about five or ten minutes and
actually show you some code because I
want to introduce this notion but that's
a little bit different from the N Queens
recursive paradigm it is recursive but
it's called recursive divide and conquer
all right and usually when we use the
term recursive divide and conquer you
you might think that it's applicable
even to the N Queens recursive code but
I from a technical term standpoint when
we say recursive divide and conquer
you're really saying that we're taking
the problem and we're dividing it up
into smaller problems so you take the
problem and you divide it into two
problems that are half the size or three
problems that are a third of the size
etc right which is not what happened in
the case of the N Queens problem right I
mean what in the case of an N Queens
problem you you took a column and you
you you actually did it eration on the
column so it potentially exploded on you
and then you had a problem that was
slightly smaller than the the N Queens
it was n effectively n minus 1 Queens
right and so so it's not n over 2 or n
over 2 or 3 and our threes in the case
of a 3-way the recursive divide and
conquer so there's there's a qualitative
difference and there's also a
quantitative difference in the sense
that these kinds of algorithms are going
to be efficient in that they're going to
run in very quickly in polynomial time
you know perhaps quadratic time we can
do some analysis for both the the merge
sort that we're going to do now and for
the tiling puzzle once we get to that
but that's something to to keep in mind
all right
so merge sort is the canonical a
recursive divide and conquer approach
and I I'll put up code for it but I'm
not going to show it to you you can look
at it in the website but I'm going to
describe the algorithm to you using a
trivial example and so I want to sort
these numbers in ascending order all
right so I have these four numbers that
I want to sort in ascending order and
obviously I could do this many different
ways and we looked at selection sort but
we this is a large array and I want to
do something more efficient than a
quadratic algorithm and then square
algorithm and merge sort which is
recursive divide and conquer fits the
bill and what merge sort says is I'm
going to split the array I'm just going
to take this array and I'm going to
split it up
into two to sub-arrays and I could do
this recursively but let's just talk
about the first step right so I'm gonna
go ahead and split this array up and I
have seventy six and thirty two and I'm
gonna call merge sort on on this on this
this smaller array and the first thing
that that merge sort does is split the
array up into something smaller and you
end up getting that all right so so this
this is this is the first thing and
that's the first split and then you end
up splitting 48 and 32 and I'm sorry at
12 at 76 32 48 12 yep I got that right
and so so far you've done nothing I mean
you just sort of broken things up and
and turn this into 4-1 arrays or one
list or what have you
right but then the fun starts where
after you do the split after you return
and so 76 as singleton is trivially
sorted so there's no work to do so
there's no more splits that you could do
there's nothing that says you can I mean
76 is a monolithic element in the array
so you can't do anything with it and so
you just leave it be and the same thing
with 32 and so on and so forth but after
your two calls returned you have to you
have to merge the two together right and
at the way you merge the two together
what your the invariant here is that
when you merge the two together they
have to be sorted in the order that you
want the overall array to be sorted
which is ascending order right so in
this case you have down at the bottom
it's trivial code because you have two
singleton lists and you just decide
which order they go into okay so that
the merge in this case would simply be
produced you would produce 32 and 76
okay and in this case the merge
reproduce 12 and 48 all right so at this
level you're going to return 32 and 76
back you can return 32 and 76 back and
here you can return 12 and 48 back okay
now it gets a little more interesting
okay now it gets a little more
interesting because now you have 32 and
76 and 12 and 48 and those are both
sorted in ascending order and you need
to merge them together right and so
if you had a 128 element list you would
go below all the way down and then you
would do some merging come up all the
way and then the the most time-consuming
step really would be taking 264 element
lists that are booked that you know the
left one is in ascending order and the
right one is in the sending order and
and then you need to merge them together
so the result is in ascending order
right that makes sense and so in this
case what the way we're gonna do this is
if you have and I can do this for for
this example or a different example but
you know what I'll just stick with but
it's 32 76 and this could be larger this
is 12 and 48 so I need to merge these
two to produce an ascending order and we
use that straightforward algorithm
that's called it the two-finger
algorithm which says I'm going to start
with my fingers pointing to the
beginning of the two arrays and I'm
going to choose the element that's
smaller and I'm going to write it into
my output array right so I'm gonna
compare 32 and 1212 with smaller so I'm
going to write 12 down and because I
picked well from this array and I didn't
pick 32
I'm gonna leave my top finger where it
is and I'm gonna move my bottom finger
of my right hand finger over to the next
element right and then I'm gonna compare
32 with 48 because this finger didn't
move and I'm gonna figure out which one
is smaller and it's 32 and I'm gonna put
that over here and then I'm gonna move
this finger because I took away 32 and
then at this point 48 is smaller and and
then I'm off this array is assuming very
end it here but if it didn't I keep
going and then the last thing I do is
put 76 star okay so that is that
recursive divide and conquer algorithm
right it's the surplus algorithm I can
think of and that is still interesting
and that you can I show you code for it
I'm not going to explain it but it's
worth it is worth looking at the overall
code and and then the merge which is the
still finger round with them is actually
the most amount of code
but the split itself as you can see is
you see as with our recursion we say if
you want to have a base case and so when
the length of the list becomes 2 I'm
just going to do that little flip this
is a sorting algorithm that only works
for a list of length 2 right but the
beauty of this is that I can keep going
down to get smaller and smaller lists
such that the sorting algorithm actually
works and this is it you know this this
is a fine sorting algorithm for a base
case right and we do have a base case
here we also have the other property
that I'm actually calling I'm making two
recursive calls with significantly
smaller problems in this case I'm using
less splicing to get the first part of
the list and the second part of the list
and I'm just calling merge sort on those
two lists right and then finally this is
the the work horse in merge sort is the
merge step there's two fingered thing
that I just described to you right that
is this merge thing and this merge thing
as you can see I'm just not a lot of
code but it's it's it's doing this this
movement and the comparisons and that's
essentially what you have there all
right so so given that context
alright given that context let's go back
to our tiling puzzle and let's talk
about this tiling puzzle and and and how
we could we could solve this tiling
puzzle all right um so so you're going
to break this courtyard up clearly
because that's really what I've been
trying to tell you in terms of recursive
divide and conquer right first question
and should look at this to raise to N
and to raise to N and look at this three
tile I I'm gonna ask you the question it
is there a solution that is is a perfect
tiling with no overlapping tiles and and
note no squares with holes in them is
someone
I finally had our hand up first go over
to my two courtyards it's impossible we
get fancy distributed by the general
case then we'll have two to the
so so two of the two air probably had
the same answer to to the 2n is not a
multiple of three I mean the only thing
that divides it is 2 right all right
so okay so that we gonna change the
problem all right we're going to say
that there's a statue of your favorite
person that is is that that that is
going to be out here and so you don't
need to you don't need to tile that okay
so now you have to raise to n to raise
to 2n minus 1 let me write that over
properly to raise to 2n minus 1 squares
now can you do this for all n clearly it
works for up for N equals 1 right and
then for N equals 2 you have what 2
raise to 4 which is 16 minus 1 15 well
that seems to work and then you get up
to I think 80 what is it to 2 raise to 6
would be 64 and so that would be 63 that
works too in general does it work it
does right so so it turns out if you
think about it if you have you can write
this out as 2 raise to n minus 1 times 2
raise to n plus 1 and you know in the
middle there you know pretend that
there's 2 raise to n so you have three
consecutive numbers and when you
multiply three consecutive numbers and
it does it's a consecutive it doesn't
matter what the numbers are the product
is always going to be a multiple of
three right because one of those things
is going to be a multiple of three and
that you know the 2 raise to n is not a
multiple of three this is not a product
of three consecutive numbers but if it
were it
and you pretended that to raise to n was
in here Matthysse one is a multiple of
three or that one is a multiple of three
so this is good so so we know that there
at least from a standpoint of volume or
our surface area if you will that this
is going to work right but as the
original problem didn't work from a
surface area standpoint right all right
so so it comes down to how am I going to
solve this problem using recursive
divide and conquer and so I can break
this up and you want to have a similar
feel to the merge sort where when you
got down to the base case of merge sort
you had this sort of trivial problem to
solve that's the beauty of divide and
conquer it becomes obvious when you have
such a small problem like one queen or I
mean that's not technically not dividing
conquer but you do get to the smaller
part but clearly in this case this is a
classic divide-and-conquer out with the
merge sort and you can see that the
first show three lines of code are the
trivial case right of to two elements
that needed to be sorted all right so
let's go back and forget that let's look
at this picture and and think about how
you'd break this up right how would I
break this up
so I think two dimensionally mergesort
was a single dimension okay
I think think two-dimensional this is
two-dimensional this is a
two-dimensional problem it's in that
sense closer to in Queens but Mozart was
single it was it was simply a single
dimension right all right I see Kevin
had father's hand up kevin has it end up
someone else all right go ahead Kevin
waters all right so let's let okay let's
do that let's let's do that you're on
the right track right and by the way
this this this particular thing you know
could be over there and I'll just do
this just to make sure you in your your
algorithm needs to work regardless of
where that statue is so maybe the the
statues over here maybe the statues over
there there's only one statue that is
covering one square but it's not
necessarily near the center it could be
even be you know anywhere you need you
need a general purpose scheme that would
work regardless of where the statue is
you know as long as it only occupies one
square right that's the only constraint
we have so you're on the right track
Kevin if someone else or body you want
to add to that
missing and what both you and Kevin have
put up the thing with mergesort was I
had exactly the same problem to solve it
was exactly the same problem it was just
smaller I needed to sort the smaller
array in ascending order and I had two
of them and it was exactly the same
problem but when I split this up into
four quarters like yours you guys are
suggesting do I have exactly the same
four problems to solve in fact can I
even solve this this 16 problem with
l-shape tiles I can so at some level I
have three problems that I can't solve
and then a smaller problem that I don't
quite know how to solve other than maybe
splitting it up even more which is kind
of interesting which is good right but
then the next time if I do go ahead and
split that then wonderful I will find
one problem that's 2x2 that I can solve
right but that doesn't solve my puzzle
okay so so I have to do one more thing
you know in order to make this look like
merge sort or any recursive divide and
conquer one of the paradigms of
recursive divide and conquer is you're
not creating new types of problems
you're creating the same type of problem
except smaller and therefore eventually
easier okay so I have to do one more
thing alright and this is an aha moment
here that I'm hoping I'm I don't want to
take an answer yet because I want you to
think about it and and perhaps arrive at
it but it's you know it's one of those
things where you're going to go oh you
know and if you don't know the answer
but but it's worth you know spending
another minute okay not a minute each of
you're thinking about it right how am I
going to set it up so these quarters so
all of this is good we're gonna split it
up into quarters but I want all four
problems to look exactly the same in the
sense that in the sense that they look I
mean this obviously looks different from
these other ones where there's a tile
missing here but there's no tile missing
over in the other three right so
how do I make all problems look the same
okay I don't you know but we need more
I'll give you 30 more seconds and I'll
give you one more hint all right all
right
the hint is place one time place one
l-shaped aisle all right yeah go for it
you set it up so you your tile the
reason I picked that picked this
l-shaped this way is because this was
the statue right so I wanted to remove a
tile from each of the other three
quarters
I'm sorry remove a square right a
tireless L shape and so this was a
missing square which was clearly you
know it was part of the specification of
the problem it has nothing to do with
the tile it's just a missing square
because there's a statue on it but what
I could do is if I oriented the tile in
this way now I have this being a smaller
problem which is 1/4 of the size of the
original problem with one square missing
this one is one square missing this one
is one square missing this one is one
square missing now that makes all of the
problems look the same now AFER's
they're not exactly the same in the
sense that the missing square is in a
different position but you know there's
some generality that we need in our
algorithm that says that eventually if I
keep breaking this up in this fashion I
just need to orient my l-shaped tile in
the appropriate way right so there's
only four different ways that that it
that an l-shaped tile is going to be
oriented right it could be oriented like
this and I won't draw on all of them it
could be oriented like that and you know
it could also be that's the same so what
else is there
oh it could be
I'll flip this way right yeah like that
and you know the fourth one so that's
what I did here this one is what I put
up there and then as I break this up the
let's just say that now I'm gonna make
four recursive calls I'm gonna place one
tile one l-shaped tile and and I'm gonna
mark off these things and I'm gonna make
four recursive calls to basically myself
except that the arguments are different
right it's the same code obviously so
when I go up here I go like that and I
hopefully this will become clear if
you're gonna do a tiling here I'm gonna
I'm gonna go focus on the top left and
I'm going to do this what am I going to
do with respect to this at this
particular corner of the courtyard how
am I going to orient at the l-shaped
tile for this one point with your
fingers exactly right so this is the
same as this I'm gonna go ahead and do
that okay
so so now I have that this problem so
I'm gonna mark that with a different
different color so I'm focused on this
problem and I've done that break and now
I have now I'm good because I have that
for two by two courtyards and each of
these four has has one square missing in
each of these four little two by two
courtyards so clearly I can solve that
right and then once I solve that I can
solve
I'd move on to this one and I move on to
this one whatever order you want all
right that's it and so the code for this
this is from a control flow standpoint
from an from a standpoint of the overall
algorithm it's extremely straightforward
it's it's almost exactly like merge sort
except that you have 4-way recursion
because you end up getting its you
dimensional and you end up getting
quarters and the only thing that's
annoying about this code to write and
also to understand which you you guys
will love I'll put this up and I'll show
you what to look for is is how you
represent this such that you get older
the values right so so you
you get an arbitrary square to begin
with that is missing and then you have
to go to the to the to the middle that's
clear you're going to go to the middle
of this courtyard and you're gonna split
it and you're going to decide which way
this l-shaped tile is oriented and then
you got to do the the splitting again
and so it's just bookkeeping I mean
that's really what this is all about
it's not algorithmically interesting
it's just bookkeeping in terms of the
orientation of these these l-shaped
aisles so if you look at the code and if
you ignore you know a bunch of these
indices of these different variables I
let me show you well first I'll show you
what what happens when you run the code
it's I'm running it for two different
kinds of courtyards and I've used a
through I guess something like s in this
case to signify a tile so you see a a a
here a is an l-shaped I'll BBB is an
l-shaped I'll FFF is an l-shaped I'll
etcetera the original specification of
the problem this is just simply an 8x8
problem had this style that you see here
that's a blank that I've covered up that
was missing I'm sorry the square missing
and and then I broke this up into two or
four four by fours and then I went all
the way up and then the first style that
I placed I pretended to place this u
tile over here I could have placed it
and then called it the a tile but this
this is essentially what you you think
of the one in the center exactly the way
this is oriented that's your u tile over
here and then you go all the way down
and explicitly
it's just the a tile that's placed first
and then the B tile and so on and so
forth and if you take a look at the code
what's the best place to start so this
is the base case at same thing as we've
talked about before uh you always need
to have a base case the base case is the
two by two and at this code places one
l-shaped tile on a two by two yard okay
um this is going to make four recursive
calls as you can see from range 4 and
there's two different kinds of recursive
calls in the sense that they're both
calling recursive tile but the arguments
the recursive tile are different for
this recursive call because it already
had the the missing square in it and
these three recursive calls that are
going to have the missing square in one
of their corners okay so so that's why
you see the the if and the else here and
if the original if for the recursive
call that already had the missing square
because it had the statue on it I gots
the if statement and the the other ones
are the ones that are in the in the in
the corners so they're the first things
it would be this would be a corner of
this one this is a corner of that one
and that's the corner of that one all
right so so that's pretty much all I all
I had this code is is you need to gaze
at it for a few minutes to figure out
that I got all the arguments correct but
from a standpoint of as I said the
control flow and the algorithm it is
hopefully a completely clear to you at
this point if not ask me questions come
to office hours have a good long weekend